[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes yo pienso firmemente que
la inteligencia artificial es la
tecnología más importante hoy en día sin
embargo tenemos un gran reto que casi
nadie está hablando y ese reto es
democratización del conocimiento de
inteligencia artificial quiere decir
cómo vamos a hacer que todas las
empresas en españa empiezan a trabajar
con inteligencia artificial y cómo vamos
vamos a hacer que todos los ciudadanos
sepan que esa inteligencia artificial y
cómo va a cambiar el mundo o cómo se
puede empezar un proyecto entonces en
este pequeño charla voy a compartir
algunas ideas de qué se está haciendo
para esto en mi país natal
finlandia
vamos a ver primero a hablar de lo bueno
que nos ofrece inteligencia artificial
hay gente que dice que inteligencia
artificial nos va a ayudar a hacer lo
imposible en el futuro porque lo pueden
podemos aplicar prácticamente en
cualquier área en cualquier industria en
cualquier proyecto y también hay
expertos que dicen que inteligencia
artificial es como la nueva electricidad
y que la inteligencia artificial es
mejor que el electricidad porque podemos
empezar a utilizarlo ahora mismo cuando
vino la red eléctrica cerraron muchos
años para instalarlo a cada pueblo
etcétera hoy en día cualquier persona
que tiene conexión de internet puede
empezar a utilizar
a la inteligencia artificial comprándolo
desde los servidores de cloud de grandes
empresas tecnológicas entonces para las
empresas españolas hay muchas
oportunidades por ejemplo se puede hacer
cada proceso de forma más rápida más
eficaz y más económica y también podemos
aumentar la productividad que es muy
importante aumentar hoy en día para
seguir siendo competitivos también
podemos innovar y hacer nuevos productos
y servicios que hoy en día no se puede
si lo aplicamos correctamente no y luego
para los individuos obviamente
inteligencia artificial va a ayudar
bastante podemos hacer tener una salud
mejor por ejemplo gracias a nuestro
asistente virtual que nos da consejos y
podemos incluso tener cosas como
educación mejor y más personalizada
todo esto si lo compaginamos con lo que
es buen uso y pico de la inteligencia
artificial que es de unión europea no se
están animando a aplicar ética a la
inteligencia artificial creo que vamos a
tener un futuro muy importante siempre y
cuando vamos a compartir esta
información con todo el mundo no
entonces algunas de las cosas que se
pueden hacer gracias a la inteligencia
artificial simplemente son como
asistencia robótica para cualquier cosa
que vamos a hacer o temas como un
transporte más seguro más eficaz a temas
como ya mencionaba salud y educación que
se está haciendo mucho en mi país natal
finlandia aplicando inteligencia
artificial para educación etcétera
etcétera etcétera entonces oportunidades
son increíbles y yo animo a todos a
empezar a pensar aprender más sobre esto
y sobre todo estar muy animado de las
oportunidades que esto presenta a todos
nosotros sin embargo tenemos este gran
reto
que actualmente creo que solamente 20%
de las empresas españolas están haciendo
algún tipo de proyectos piloto o están
investigando cómo utilizar la
inteligencia artificial 80% no están
haciendo eso y también sobre todo y más
importante hay muchos ciudadanos que hoy
en día no saben cómo el mundo va a
cambiar debido a la inteligencia
artificial entonces lo que propongo es
que vamos a copiar simplemente algunas
ideas que se están haciendo en mi país
natal
finlandia entonces cuando nacieron mis
padres en los años 40 finlandia era uno
de los países más pobres en europa
después de que la segunda guerra mundial
y hoy en día es uno de los países más
ricos y digamos no quizás los más ricos
pero más competitivas en todos los
sectores y la razón es educación vale
entonces hay que invertir más en
educación y en este caso sobre todo hay
que invertir más en empezar a educar a
todo el mundo sobre inteligencia
artificial que se ha hecho en finlandia
por ejemplo en el último año pues sea
empezar con un curso gratuito este curso
se llama elements of wight cualquier
persona lo puede hacer desde su casa lo
ha hecho la universidad de helsinki y lo
interesante es que fue un poco impulsado
por el gobierno y muchos líderes
diciendo que tenemos que formar 1% de
los finlandeses sobre esto no entonces
después de hacer este curso ahora
se ha hecho una copia del curso en sueco
también en holanda también se ha están
haciendo un curso y lo que yo animo es
que en españa no habrían no solamente un
curso gratuito sino que muchos cursos
gratuitos porque inteligencia artificial
tiene tantas cámaras diferentes por
ejemplo la visión artificial podría ser
un tema que solamente eso abre
tendríamos que tener muchos muchos
cursos no y aparte finlandia fue uno de
los primeros países de publicar un plan
estratégico
de como el país tiene que utilizar la
inteligencia artificial hoy en día han
publicado tres informes y lo que esto ha
hecho es que no solamente hay muchas
empresas que ahora han empezado a pensar
que ostras tenemos que cambiar tenemos
que hacer algo sino también muchas
instituciones han empezado a crear
herramientas y recursos para empresas y
para ciudadanos para poder adaptarse a
esta nueva era
aquí en españa no se ha publicado
todavía lo que es el plan estratégico y
esperamos que se va a hacer en el futuro
unión europea ha dicho que hasta
mediados de este año todos los países de
unión europea tendría que publicar su
plan estratégico adicionalmente hay
otras propuestas interesantes solamente
mencionar a algunos
uno de ellos es que el ministro
finlandés de economía muy curiosamente
la semana pasada hizo un concurso con el
ministro sueco diciendo que vamos a
hacer un concurso entre países vamos a
ver qué país puede formar más sus
ciudadanos sobre inteligencia artificial
y su impacto aquí hablamos de que no
todos tienen que ser progre
mayores pero todos tienen que saber como
inteligencia artificial va a cambiar
nuestra vida nuestra sociedad entonces
el ministro sueco dijo que claro que sí
entonces ahora mismo hay un concurso
entre los países entonces algo muy muy
positivo yo espero que aquí podemos
tener un concurso entre españa portugal
francia italia todo a todos los países
no entonces hay muchos muchos ejemplos
en mi campo que es la educación por
ejemplo colaboro con una universidad que
se llama jábaga help ya es muy curioso
porque su rector ha dicho que dentro de
dos años y ya no se va a ser y ya no se
va a llamar universidad sino que se va a
llamar plataforma de educación donde
cualquier persona puede venir y comprar
y [ __ ] un nuevo curso de tres meses
mini cursos que ayudan a la gente a
aprender nuevas conocimientos y
habilidades porque en el mundo de
trabajo va a cambiar drásticamente y
necesitamos tener más acceso a este tipo
de cosas entonces también animó a todas
las universidades copiar estas ideas
porque necesitamos muchísimos más
nuevos y nuevos cursos nuevas maneras de
poder aprender y hablamos de cursos
cortos de tres meses no de tres años
cuatro años etcétera yo también estoy
colaborando con con esta universidad
otra cosa interesante que han hecho es
como una pequeña máquina de inteligencia
artificial donde está actora la
información de qué cursos se puede
estudiar junto con todos los puestos de
trabajo que hay actualmente en helsinki
en capital de finlandia entonces cada
alumno puede utilizar esta máquina o
cada profesora y puede analizar qué
trabajos ahora mismo hay por ejemplo hay
muchos trabajos que no se encuentran
suficientes personas y podemos decir o
podemos mostrar a un alumno que oye si
antes de graduarte dentro de seis meses
si aprendes algo de inteligencia
artificial o propia y no otra cosa
quizás
vas a poder tener mejor salida en
después de graduarte entonces esto es
fundamental porque hoy en día tenemos
mucha gente estudiando que no sepan qué
va a suceder cuándo van a graduar
es un ejemplo de buen uso de
inteligencia artificial etc etc
también se están empezando a utilizar
muchos chats potts dentro de las
universidades que ayudan a responder a
las preguntas frecuentes etcétera
una cosa que sí que es muy curioso entre
diferencias entre estos dos países es el
uso de bibliotecas generales en este
final del año pasado finlandia start of
en donde se hizo un gran edificio que
costó creo que más de 200 millones y no
era un museo o un mega hotel o un centro
comercial no es una biblioteca y es un
biblioteca que todo el mundo pueden ir y
curiosamente una de las cosas que hacen
es en esta biblioteca son son cursos
gratuitos y charlas gratuitas sobre la
inteligencia artificial y sobre todo
cómo la sociedad va a cambiar en base de
esto también hay otras bibliotecas en
otros ciudades donde hay cursos por
ejemplo para los jubilados y para la
gente
mayor para que ellos también aprenden
cómo utilizar diferentes aplicaciones y
cómo su vida va a cambiar en esta nueva
era digital
adicionalmente también hay cursos por
ejemplo temas así como crear nuevos
robots que se crean utilizando la
impresión 3d etcétera etcétera entonces
simplemente es contar que aquí en españa
hay grandes oportunidades porque pensar
que españa es 10 hay 10 10 veces más
habitantes que en finlandia esto quiere
decir que hay 10 veces más datos
inteligencia artificial sólo funciona
cuando hay gran uso de datos y hay
muchas muchas oportunidades pero hay que
empezar a trabajar ahora mismo con estas
oportunidades y hay que pensar que
necesitamos obviamente muchos más gente
que pueden programar inteligencia
artificial pero sobre todo necesitamos
muchísima gente que piensan como
diferentes campos van a cambiar y cuál
es ese impacto y sobre todo cómo podemos
preparar a la gente al gran destrucción
que viene en el mercado de trabajo
entonces yo lo que propongo es
simplemente empezar a dar más cursos
gratuitos que incluso cada uno de
vosotros podéis empezar a crear o pensar
junto con universidades o sin
universidades y también empezar a hacer
diferentes concursos diferentes
actividades un poco como se está
haciendo hoy en día con el nation y hay
que entender que hay expertos que dicen
que conocimiento de inteligencia
artificial es como un derecho humano
hoy en día me parece muy interesante esa
reflexión y yo pienso que los que
conocen inteligencia artificial y cómo
cambiar diferentes campos es un poco lo
mismo que anteriormente eran las
personas que conocían por ejemplo sabían
leer y escribir los que sabían leer y
escribir tenían grandes oportunidades
mientras los que no no tenían mucha
salida lo mismo va a suceder con la
inteligencia artificial si no vamos a
empezar a trabajar y sobre todo un miedo
que que hay es que vamos a tener grandes
problemas sociales
si tenemos sólo una parte de la
población que están trabajando con esta
tecnología tan increíble y muchos otros
que no lo entienden o no lo están
aprendiendo y no tienen acceso a
entenderlo
entonces eso es lo que yo quería
compartir ahora y espero que todos
empezamos a trabajar con estas ideas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]